[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr peterson jordan
thank you so much for that
a lot of the way in which the debate has
been conducted here in cambridge on free
speech has been rather dry in fact it's
been heated but quite dry quite arid
we've been thinking a lot in
philosophical terms and we're talking a
lot about milton and and and mill
but what you've done for us tonight is
show us the existential power
of being able to speak freely
uh that if we care about well-being we
care about psychological flourishing
uh and we care about what aristotle
called eudaimonia happiness well-being
flourishing then we should prize
truth and the free pursuit of truth
above
uh
all else
now
the time has come for discussion for q a
this is what we like to do here in fact
this is this is what it's all about
uh so
if anyone would like to kick off um i'm
vincent here is going to traffic the
microphone around if i could just ask
you to speak into the microphone just
for recording purposes and for
amplification purposes uh vincent you
can't miss him he's in ah
[Applause]
a bone white suit in the middle of uh
cambridge november
uh
so
just make sure that your uh make sure
that you put your hand up uh clearly so
that he can uh spot you and then since
vincent will have the mic uh i'll let dr
peterson pick the questions as they are
emily
hello dr peterson thank you so much for
coming to talk to us
so
i um i have a question it's sort of
personal so i've recently become
convinced that i'm called to
work either in politics or at least in
the public intellectual space and i want
to do that because i really love my
country and i want to try to help
preserve the values that have have you
know been at the foundation of our
country
but i'm i'm worried that i'm going to be
seduced by the loss for power and i was
wondering if you had any advice for how
to fight the lust for power
well that's kind of a germain question
altogether isn't it because
part of the
cultural battle that we all find
ourselves enveloped in is
partially due to the claim that there's
virtually nothing other than the lust
for power
and you know i would say
fair enough in some limited sense
which
and that's
that bears directly on your question
because
you see that as a temptation that might
be powerful enough to bend and distort
you as you attempt to make your way
through let's say the halls of power
well
[Music]
i heard recently from a reliable source
that putin's conversion to orthodox
christianity might be genuine
and then you might think well if you're
atheistic
well that's not necessarily a good thing
or maybe you think it's a bad thing or
maybe you think it's
an irrelevant issue and you may also
think it's a lie but
i would say that
i would be more inclined to trust
someone who thinks there's something
higher than himself
and then you might say well what is it
that's higher than ourselves and that's
worth thinking about and we all need to
think about this regardless of the
particulars of our religious belief and
i would say
again from a clinical perspective
service to others is really something
people who are depressed tend to use the
pronouns i and me
much more frequently than people who
aren't depressed and i'm not saying that
people get depressed because they're
selfish i'm not saying that at all i'm
saying that
one of the way out one of the roots out
of depression appears to be
an increase in service to other people
and i think the reason for that is
because we aren't power mad demons at
the core even though we may be tempted
by such things and that we find
the genuine meaning that offsets genuine
suffering in the genuine service to
others and i think it's a big mistake to
be cynical especially prematurely about
such things as political activity
because they're necessary despite let's
say their adversarial and uh
and uh
party-centered nature
partisan nature
you have to be clear about what you
serve
and why
and that has to be held higher always
than mere
victory mere
operationalized victory or instrumental
victory it's a very very difficult thing
to to negotiate particularly because in
the political realm
in some sense you have to defeat your
enemy right because you have to win the
election and the other people have to
lose it's a binary choice but so often i
see in partisan discussion the
proclivity to assume that all the ill
will and malevolence resides on the
other side of the chamber
and that's a big mistake and you could
think about that more deeply too is that
we all have to put we all need a place
to place the existence of malevolence
right because malevolence clearly exists
and we're all
suffer from the weight of malevolent
history
right because even the grounds we walk
on here which this is a remarkable and
wonderful place i mean english soil is
soaked with blood just like the soil of
every place in the world that's part of
the human heritage and all of us bear
the marks of that conflict in some sense
in our souls partly because of the
possibility for us to engage in that but
also partly because part of the reason
we're here in all this privilege is
because of all that catastrophe
well the best way to localize that
malevolence is inside you
right and to remember that the enemy
that you're fighting with the greatest
enemy that you ever fight with is in
your own heart and that'll also stop you
from confusing
that true source of malevolence let's
say with your mere political enemies and
that isn't to say that you won't
encounter malevolent behavior although
most of it in the political sphere
as it is everywhere most of it is more
ignorance than malevolence although
willful blindness certainly plays a
large role and so you need to know
what it is that you're serving and i
would say one of the ways to do that
practically or a couple of ways to do
that practically is you need a good team
around you the people you really trust
and who can watch you
and who do it with a certain degree of
impartiality and who are disagreeable
enough to talk to you when you do
something wrong so you need trusted
advisors and then the other thing i
would say is
you really need to listen to your
constituents
because they will tell you what the
problems are if you listen to them and
if you really listen to them well then
you'll have your feet on the ground
which is where they should be
and you'll know what the problems are
and you will win elections
because what people really want from
their leaders is to be listened to and
then for those leaders to articulate
what they've heard
in the halls of let's say influence and
power
and so if you know those things if you
know you need to listen you need to get
in touch with the people you're
representing as regularly as you
possibly can and mostly to listen
um i knew a man in canada who started a
political party which is a very
difficult thing to do and not only did
he start it but he wrote it to
sufficient success though that he became
the leader of the opposition in canada
within about 10 years
and i asked him how he did that because
it's like well really how did you do
that that's actually really hard and he
said he would go out from constituency
to constituency and make his stump
speeches but what he really liked was
the q and a's because people would tell
him what their problems were then he
knew what the problems were and out of
the dialogue would also emerge the
answers that the audience found
compelling and so not only would they
tell them what the problems were but
they would tell them the answers they
would like to have it have have what
instituted to solve those problems
it's the same thing that comedians do
when they
when they finesse finesse their acts in
front of live audiences before they
practice them in front of a large
audience they lit they tell jokes and
the audience either laughs or they don't
if they laugh then you keep that joke
and if they don't you throw it out and
soon you're just as funny as the
audience can possibly manage and it's
the same thing you can also do that in a
dark manner by the way which is what
hitler did
so he could utter terrible things and
wait for a response and collect those
and so then you become the embodiment of
the shadow of your people
so i would recommend that you probably
don't do that
thank you very much you're welcome
thank you dr peterson um
my question is what does this uh
listening posture look like over time um
and with your knowledge of personal
psychology i think we can all say we've
somewhere encountered one of those
relationships where one person does all
the work and the other person can't
engage in this even if they have been
listened to
over and over and over again
but
at our society level um
if that does happen now let's try it i
totally agree with you let's let's
listen
um
if we wind up in this sometimes it's
always listening and it never turns into
listening back
um
right what what what's that like over
time you do test for reciprocity
so children for example when children
are investigating play potential play
partners on the playground
they'll
they'll come up to a child let's assume
a child of roughly the same age because
that would be the most common situation
maybe we're talking about kids who are
four or five years old and they'll throw
out a play gesture
that's rather simple so maybe that a
two-year-old could manage and then if
the person manages a proper response
then they throw out a little more
sophisticated gesture and if the person
responds appropriately then they ratchet
up to just above their developmental
level and then they play like that at
that level and that'll make them friends
and so partly what they're testing for
there continually is whether there's
something approximating reciprocal
altruism right it's it's tit-for-tat in
the positive sense and i would say that
well we know there's actually a
literature on this which is quite
interesting this is also something very
practical to know and i'll get to
another practicality here
so
there have been psychologists who've
done empirical investigations into what
predicts the longevity of a relationship
and so here's one experiment that was
conducted multiple times and i believe
this is very reliable data
so imagine you have the two partners in
a marriage each rate
the number of encounters they have with
their other partner a day it's kind of
an
arbitrary and subjective measure but it
doesn't matter you might say well i
talked to my wife eight times today we
had eight different interactions
and then you'd say well
did you rate those for whether they're
positive or negative then you can
calculate a ratio of positive to
negative and then you can use the ratio
to predict the longevity of the
relationship
and the data show that if
the
relationship interactions fall below
five positive to one negative then the
relationship deteriorates and is
generally doomed
and so and so five to one that's
preponderance of positive interactions
but we're wired so that negative
interactions hurt us more than positive
interactions help us if they are of the
same magnitude so for example people
will work harder to avoid a loss of five
dollars than they will to attain a gain
of five dollars and you might say well
why is that and the answer is you can be
absolutely dead but there's only so
happy you can be and so it's better to
err on the side of conservatism in the
domain of negative emotion
and so but interestingly enough um
if the interactions rise so that they
exceed 11 positive to one negative the
relationship also deteriorates
and so what that suggests is that
there's some
it's kind of like smiles with teeth
right you want a fair bit of positive
emotion and reflection from your partner
but you don't want them to be a naive
dependent pushover who's afraid to stand
up for themselves and so
you want to you know because you're a
nasty horrible human being and now and
then you poke your partner just to see
if there's anything there because that's
what you're like and if you find out
there isn't you'll run roughshod over
them and you think you won't but you
will especially if they're very good at
implicitly encouraging that which
dependent people sometimes are
so so you do assess for reciprocity
and the basic rule is
you want
approximately equal reciprocity in
relationships that you want to maintain
now maybe you know you have enough
additional resource to be the giver more
often than receiver in some
relationships but i don't even think
that really works that well with
children
you know i mean you obviously have to
take care of them but it's not like they
don't deliver the goods to you if you
have a good relationship with them and
and you want to you want to some degree
to enforce that reciprocity
now you might say well what happens in
relationships where that's impossible
and well i give you a practical piece of
a suggestion on that front and this is
another thing you can do in your own
household this is so useful man if you
get good at doing this your life will
get so much better you can't believe it
is
watch the people around you
and whenever they do anything that you
would like to see repeated on a regular
basis
tell them exactly what they did in
detail with you know be positive about
it obviously
and and just indicate that you noticed
and because i saw this when i was
grading student essays you know and so i
taught this seminar for a long time and
i was trying to teach kids how to write
they were in their fourth year of
university in the honors psych program
you'd think they'd bloody well already
know how to write but they didn't
and so
i'd have them write a four page essay on
a given topic and then they had to
rewrite that to a six page essay and
then they had to rewrite that to an age
eight page essay and
the first essay i graded i it was only
five percent of their grade and i told
them i'm going to cut you into ribbons
but it doesn't matter because it's you
know five percent of your grade and so
they could tolerate that and generally
by the third essay they had written the
best thing they'd ever written in their
life and they learned so fast it was
unbelievable but one of the things i
noticed was that they did a little
testing with the first essay they'd hand
in something it was just like
god
formulaic
boring they weren't in it at all you
know there was nothing of the person in
there there was no thought there was
just the kind of cycle babble that they
learned especially if they were in
faculties of education and
and it was dry and dull and and
everything about it was wrong and so
those are hard to grade right what's
wrong with my essay well the words
aren't right the phrases they're not so
good they're not organized well into
sentences the sentences aren't sequenced
well in the paragraphs the peregrines
paragraphs don't make a coherent
argument and the entire thing is empty
but other than that no problem it was
often easier just to rewrite those
essays than to grade them no so in any
case though one of the things i did
learn was that even in an essay like
that there is usually like
one sentence or two sentences buried on
like page three that was an actual
thought
and reasonably clearly stated and
somewhat gripping you know it was like
the person popped out from all the
background rubbish and said
well what about this
and if you saw that and checked it and
said hey you hit the mark right there
the next essay would be like two-thirds
that and that was really fun to see and
then maybe by the third essay maybe it
was all like that and then they were
really thrilled it's like wow i wrote
this you know and sort of the
culmination well it was a fourth year
seminar it was the culmination of their
their career as a psychology
undergraduate so that was great fun but
you can do that in your own household if
if
if if the envious part of you isn't
jealous of the revelation of the
goodness of the person
and so here's the opposite tact if you
want to do this so imagine that you're a
man who's managed to attract a mate and
he believes he's punched above his
weight so this woman is more attractive
let's say more vivacious more desirable
than he deserves so that's going to
grate on his soul a fair bit right
partly because
her shining casts a dim light on his
lack of utility let's say and so
you can imagine someone like that being
prone to jealousy
for obvious reasons and so the best tact
to
manage in a situation like that if
you're that man is to wait till your
wife dresses herself up in a
particularly attractive manner and then
either fail to notice
by occupying yourself with something
trivial while she's attempting to gain
your attention or by criticizing her
directly for what she's just managed to
do
and if you do that 50 times let's say
you can be sure that she'll never reveal
her attractiveness to anyone else for
the rest of her life including you and
you'll get exactly what you deserved
so that's the opposite of watching
people carefully now i learned this in
part from skinner b.f skinner the famous
animal behaviorist because he was very
he used all sorts of reinforcement
contingencies to shape animal behavior
and skinner was unbelievably good at
this he trained
pigeons in world war ii to guide
missiles by pecking at photographs so
they could map the photographs onto the
missile trajectory viewing the territory
underneath and peck accurately enough to
guide the missile to its destination
that was discontinued as the technology
for guided missiles developed but
skinner could do that and you know we
think pigeons well they're not that
bright it's like
they're smarter than you think pigeons
that's why they can live in cities
that's not easy for a bird to pull off
you know it's not their natural habitat
and so but skinner although he would use
punishment technically speaking which is
the uh the application of a certain
amount of pain or threat which is the
use of anxiety but what he believed was
most effective was reward but it
required a tremendous amount of
attention so for example if skinner was
trying to train a rat to climb up a
little ladder and then across the ladder
and then maybe do a pirouette and come
down which he could do with no problem
he'd wait he'd just watch the rat
and then when it get close to the ladder
he gives a food palette now his rats
were starved by the way down to three
quarters of their normal body weight so
they were pretty eager to work for food
it's not something you necessarily saw
in the methodology section of the papers
but
um well
and that's not a critique of of skinner
it's just an indication of how
simplification takes place in laboratory
experiments but in any case he'd wait
for the rat to get near the ladder and
give it a food pellet
and soon the rat would be hanging around
the ladder quite a lot
and then now and then just more or less
randomly the rat would put a paw up on
the ladders food pellet well then the
rat would hang around the bottom of the
ladder with pop well if he did that
continually through observation he could
get the route to do pretty much anything
that
you could imagine a rat could do and
then maybe some things you couldn't
imagine and this isn't a manipulative
technique by the way although it can be
used that way it it's not effective
unless you do it with a certain degree
of wisdom you want to think well what do
you want your house
how about peace tranquility
happiness and humor something like that
it's not a bad first pass approximation
and you've got to get that in your head
it's like
do you want that or do you want the
delights of endless martyrdom
because you have to make a choice and
you might think i wouldn't pick
martyrdom it's like
really
really you wouldn't eh you'd pick peace
and happiness and humor and so
everywhere you go that's all you're ever
surrounded with
it's like highly on highly improbable so
don't be so sure you're aiming up but if
you can orient yourself in that
direction and then and carefully and and
knowing full well what the hellish
alternative is because you need to know
that then you can watch and see well
when
when is this manifesting itself in the
people around me and then you can tell
them in detail i noticed sun i noticed
today we're having a discussion at
dinner you know when you made a
spectacularly witty remark right at the
right time and it was provocative but
not annoying and so good work and then
the kid thinks oh my god he noticed and
then he's like twice as funny the next
day and maybe not in some unbearable
manner and that really works it really
works but like i said you have to quell
the envy that would otherwise beset you
and you have to want to aim up and then
you have to not be jealous of the other
person's goodness and you have to be
extremely attentive but man as a
transformation technique even in
extraordinarily difficult relationships
which goes back to your point
there isn't anything i know of that's
more effective and i've been working
with moderate democrats in the united
states recently and with a number of
republicans and suggesting that
to the democrats that when the
republicans do something that isn't
absolutely malevolent and stupid in your
opinion
you might want to just say something
like
that's not as bad as it could have been
you know something at least and the same
for the republicans in relationship to
the democrats and that because it's also
one of the ways that you can reduce the
for tap proclivity right
you want to give the devil as do
especially when you're not actually
talking to the devil but just the person
who's sitting across you let's say in
the house it's an unbelie and people
that's another issue i mean
if you want people to appreciate having
you around
learning how to listen that is that is a
skill that is absolutely unbeatable and
this
this uh
technique of summarizing to their
satisfaction that works like a charm and
it's not you know you might be a little
awkward when you first try it and might
feel a little manipulative because
you're not that good at it but if you
get
if you get expert at it
it's and you have the greatest
conversations with everyone you know i
had people in my clinical practice who
were extraordinarily impaired
intellectually and suffering from all
sorts of assorted pathologies in
addition to that and if i was listening
to them properly they were as
fascinating as anybody i had on the say
more able and competent end of the
spectrum and you learn so much because
there is nothing that people won't tell
you if you listen
it is absolutely amazing what people
will tell you and so quickly they'll
reveal things they didn't even know
about themselves and they need to know
those things often they've been hidden
for years
it's so rewarding and then this this use
of
attentive
reward that's also it's it's
it's so it's it's fun in a game-like
sense once you learn to play it because
you're watching you think i'll just wait
this person's going to do something good
sooner or later it's like pat good work
and people are so thrilled that that
little
manifestation of goodness in their heart
that managed to sneak out past their
cynicism and boredom was recognized
they're so
what is it what is it
it it it restores their faith in what's
good inside them it really does it's
unbelievably powerful and so that can
work if you're if you're embroiled in a
difficult relationship you know and you
can't escape easily or maybe you can't
escape on moral grounds that
listening that's that helps a lot you
might have to listen a lot but that use
of judicious reward man that's a
powerful technique
so
dr peterson thank you so much for your
work and your passionate defensive free
speech in relation to
and therapy as well the uk government's
currently consulting on banning
so-called conversion therapy and i
wondered what your view was as a
therapist on that in relation to talking
therapy in particular
well
the first thing i would say about that
is that as soon as it's
termed conversion therapy
the argument's already over
right because this is one of the things
conservative politicians are
particularly bad at this by the way
there there that's why i mentioned at
the beginning that you should never
discuss viewpoint diversity i mean you
think about what you're doing when you
discuss viewpoint diversity you think
you're conservative let's say that
you've just pulled a fast one on the
lefties it's like you're so you know
gung-ho about diversity
what about viewpoint diversity and you
don't even notice that you just
subordinated the highest value in the
hierarchy of values to diversity
you lose buddy
it doesn't matter what argument you make
after you've done that it's like i
defined the terms of the debate
i established the questions
i you seated the terminological ground
you can flap your lips all night but
you're not going to change that
and so the conversion therapy issue
right there is the way as soon as that's
framed in that manner it's a lost cause
a guy had a client a young man who was
being pressured quite intensely into a
homosexual relationship by someone who
was attracted to him and he was
genuinely confused about his sexuality
and certainly about how to respond
well i wasn't going to do conversion
therapy i mean i don't know what what's
up with this kid i have no idea and
neither did he and so the goal there is
if someone comes to you who's confused
about their sexuality and
like have you met someone who isn't
confused about their sexuality it's
really complicated especially when
you're 16
you know well you listen and you try to
sort them out and if you have any sense
you realize that you have enough trouble
with your own destiny
to not bother imposing your viewpoint
moral or otherwise on this teenager you
want to help them come to their own
conclusions and it's an axiom of
clinical practice that only those
formulations that come from the client
themselves
will result in anything approximating
lasting behavioral change so you know
you could come to me and i could give
you advice and you might even think it
was good advice but you're not going to
take it because
you can't even give yourself advice and
take it how are you going to take it
from a relative stranger but if you go
through the process of thinking it
through like really deeply thinking it
through and you draw your own
conclusions
and then maybe you practice their
implementation there is some possibility
of change and you just can't do that by
well like conversion therapy
so and it's partly because
there is enough temperamental
variability in people
that you don't know what the right
answer is for the person who comes to
see you no more than you know what the
right answer is for your children or for
your mate and hopefully what you do is
in this process of dialogical
relationship and and mutual revelation
the person's pathway becomes clearer and
i do believe that that
the
goodwill exchange of thought
does in fact
what constitutes that process
so
i yeah as soon as it's conversion
therapy the game's already lost
but
there's a fair bit of fluidity in human
sexuality
and people have to come to terms with
that you know you might say as a rule of
thumb and i think this is true your life
is going to be a lot simpler if you
adopt something approximating
traditional sexual rules
and so you step outside of that confine
at your peril but it might also be your
necessity
who's to say
so when you help the per in humility you
help the person discover that for
themselves
and so
so i think the talk of conversion
therapy you know if someone's saying
well i'll cure you or cure you of your
homosexuality it's like well
it's not a disease first of all and so
it doesn't need a cure and probably you
can't do that anyways and it's not
it's not the proper way to advertise
clinical services let's say because that
isn't really how a clinical relationship
works
so the argument in some sense is beside
the point as far as i'm concerned
so
thank you so much for such an amazing
talk and
the definition you you gave of freedom
of speech i think is not heard enough
um something i would like you to perhaps
talk about is many people
talk about the failure of the university
as the failure of the marketplace
and many say the failure of their
leaders or the university uh the
university
setting as a failure of the marketplace
and
some say it is because freedom of speech
has fallen out of fashion and is not um
used enough and being criticized too
much
my question is do you think
the marketplace of idea if you believe
in such a thing can be fixed by imposing
i mean poising
uh putting at um more upfront what
you've been redefining as freedom of
speech or is there something in the
marketplace of idea that is broken and
perhaps we should fight specifically
some ideas all the time and it's not
good enough to have them on the
marketplace of ideas that are very evil
and bad themselves is that well it might
not be good enough but it's the best we
have
that's the thing you know and it's also
the case that substitutions tend to make
things worse
we don't have anything well what do we
have except for the free expression of
ideas we have
tyranny and conflict because
the alternative to politics is war it's
not peace that's for sure peace that's
hard man that's a hard thing to attain
and so you have the intense battleground
of ideas and you know the people who are
concerned about uh let's say offense
like they have their point you know
words can hurt and they can hurt deeply
but they don't hurt as much as sticks
and they don't hurt as much as knives
so
it's a little bit of what ails you use
you might say to stave off something far
worse and that doesn't mean that the
intensity of discussion
i mean you can have discussions that are
incredibly upsetting
but the question is well what do you
have when you don't have them
and if you think that what you have by
not having those discussions is peace
then
you're either
naive willfully blind or malevolent
those are the options
so i mean i've seen in my clinical
practice one thing i got deeply
convinced of
and it wasn't something i wanted to be
convinced of i would say is i never saw
anyone in my clinical practice ever get
away with anything
not even once you know so they'd come
because they were miserable for one
reason or another and sometimes deeply
miserable and we would trace back the
genesis of the mis misery there's always
almost always an act of deception at its
root either their own deception of
themselves or some other some other
person who putatively loved them
deceiving them
and so it was unbelievably painful to
walk through that in this free speech
sort of manner but the alternative which
was living with the
insane tension that accompanies
the unrevealed truth let's say in the
bosom of a dysfunctional family like as
terrible as it is wading through the
monstrosities living with them endlessly
as they grow
that is no solution and so we don't want
to be
pollyanna about this
like there's nothing
free speech does not lack savagery
but compared to the alternative it's
it's infinitely better and it's the only
valid pathway to
peace except maybe the peace of the
grave you know i mean if you and i
disagree and i kill you well
that's the end of that argument
but it's not so good for you
you know and it's really not the end of
the argument anyways because
the probability that you are revealing
in your opposition to my thought
something that will then reveal itself
within me in opposition to my thought is
almost certain
and so we have to hash through the ideas
to make peace
and you know the idea if free speech you
say free speech has fallen out of
fascists like was thought fallen out of
unfashion because they're the same thing
like most people
i would say
95 you know six percent of people buy
books
okay how many people engage in internal
dialogical critical self-evaluation
10
maybe you you it takes a lot of training
you think what you have to do
a thought has to reveal itself to you in
the theater of your imagination and so
that happens to everyone to to a lesser
greater degree you know some people have
a thought a month and some people are
just flooded with them constantly it's a
temperamental variable and variable
associated with intelligence but
once the thought emerges you can either
accept it as a revealed truth which is
the general course of action you know a
thought occurs to you
and because you're a naive thinker you
just think well that's how it is but
let's say you're a bit trained you can
divide yourself into two avatars one
takes the pro side and one takes the con
side and you can have the debate
internally but you have to be
unbelievably highly trained to do that
now all of you people or the vast
majority of you do that as a matter of
course but don't be thinking that's the
way people work because it isn't
most of what passes for thought and i'm
not being cynical about this and i'm not
looking down on people
you know people all people have their
their their talents and
and and their abilities and
some people are good at dialogical
dialectic thinking some people don't
have that skill particularly the way
that most people think is by talking you
know they and you see this if you have a
close relationship with someone perhaps
who isn't as intellectually inclined as
you
they'll be pondering something and
they'll sort of offer a thought in it in
a questioning sort of manner and it's an
invitation it's like well i thought of
this and
i'm kind of scared of it or i'm doubtful
about it and what do you think of it
and then you play
the role of what would otherwise be an
internal avatar and they play the
opposite role and maybe you switch you
know from time to time if it's kind of
playful and you evaluate the thought
well that can't fall out of fashion it's
like
that's like reading a map has fallen we
need to get somewhere but reading a map
has fallen out of fashion it's like well
we're not going to get anywhere then are
we because that's how you get places and
there's no that's why i said earlier
freedom of speech is not just another
freedom among freedoms and certainly not
another right among rights it's
certainly not and that right is
certainly not granted to us by the
social contract or a derivative of
government fiat that's an absolute
misapprehension which is why i think as
well that there has to be something like
for atheists and believers alike a
divine hierarchy of value outside the
political process to which the political
process refers and one of the wonderful
things about the english law common law
tradition is it's grounded in such a
metaphysical reality such that we have
all the rights there are
except those that are expressed
expressly forbidden to us by the common
law tradition it's like yes good work
english people
so you know as opposed to french civil
law let's say
so because there you're granted the
rights by the state and that's just
your rights are not a social construct
that's just simply not the case it's not
the case psychologically or
physiologically for that matter
so
hi um first of all i'd like to say thank
you for having the courage to pursue the
truth and i'm very proud that you're
canadian especially since truth has been
so fraught lately in canadian politics
my question is what would you say to
someone who has been through a traumatic
experience
and wants to avoid the culture of
victimhood that encourages people to
identify with their trauma and
capitalize off of being the most
victimized person
okay well there's two things that i
address there people say this courage
they say they talk to me about my
courage fairly frequently and that's not
right exactly
like i just learned to be afraid of the
right thing
and i really mean that i mean i saw
an endless repetition in my clinical
practice and in my own private life when
my eyes were open
the consequences of not saying what was
true
it's like whatever hell you might fall
into by opening your mouth when you have
something to say that isn't popular it's
nothing like the hell that you're going
to envelop yourself in if you lose
control of your own tongue and mind
and i like i said in my clinical
practice i never saw anyone get away
with anything even once
and so all you have in a situation like
that is what is the truth now you know
of course you only have your
approximations to the truth but that's
better than nothing and so you need to
be afraid of the right thing and you
should be afraid of contaminating your
soul with deceit that's what you should
be afraid of that will definitely do you
in and i know exactly how what happens
is
you know garbage in garbage out the old
programmer's saying goes and so
you'll fill your head with nonsense and
no one will call you on it except you
but you can steal that voice if you try
hard enough
you just wait until you get in real
trouble
you know one day there'll come a point
where you have to make a decision and
the decision is the difference between
life and death or worse between someone
else's life and death or worse
between health and the suffering that's
worse than death
and because you've compromised yourself
to such a degree you will not be able to
rely on your judgment and you will make
the mistake you shouldn't make
and then you're done
and that will absolutely happen
so you tell mistruths
voluntarily at your exceptional peril
and you avoid the unpleasant truths that
you might have to delve into in all
their messiness at your absolute peril
and the peril of everyone around you and
so if you see that
you become afraid of that that's hell
and
hell is worse than death
so and i mean that most sincerely
so okay and so that's the courage issue
and then you asked about sorry i'm sorry
i
obliterated the last part of your
question
traumatic experience and wants to avoid
the culture of victimhood
um or ideas yeah
well
well
the first the first thing is
well if you want to avoid that you're
sort of on the right path already right
because you have some vision of what it
might be like not to be traumatized to
not be a victim well
first of all i mean in some sense
there's no shortage of victimhood i mean
you know the existential psychotherapist
in the 50s taking a page from heidegger
talked about throneness right the
arbitrary nature of our existence i mean
here you are you you have the ethnicity
and race that was bestowed upon you you
had no choice in that you're
the victim and the beneficiary of this
particular historical moment you know
you and you're the victim and
beneficiary of all the atrocity and the
wonders of the past
you deal with your own emotions you deal
with the fact of this specific time and
place all of that and there is a sense
of
well there's a sense of mortality
certainly that's associated that with
fineitude and mortality and you can
easily say in some sense that we're all
victimized deeply by our own
susceptibility to vulnerability and
tragedy
and i think that's true but
but then the question is well
what's the best way of dealing with that
and
falling prey to it
when my daughter was young she was very
ill
and one of the things we told her
repeatedly and which i think she did
very well to her credit was
often she was too ill really to be able
to go to school because she couldn't
wake up in the morning and she was in
pain and but she needed to go to school
and well one of the things we told her
was
don't use your illness as an excuse
right because you're already in trouble
kit you know you got your problems and
it they're serious but if you can hold
on to the distinction between the part
of you that can in spite of this and the
part that can't because of it and not
blur that distinction then that's one
more thing you have on your side while
you're attempting to struggle through
this and to her credit
she managed that and quite pristinely
and that was extraordinarily helpful it
was very difficult at times after she
had had her hip replaced
she she couldn't get around that well
and so we decided to put her in a
motorcycle course which was rather
terrifying thing to do since she just
had a hip replacement but she needed to
have a scooter to get around and so she
went with her mother to this motorcycle
uh course and they were driving
motorcycles not scooters
and at one point one of the people who
was being trained wiped out on the
motorcycle and you know it was rather
traumatic let's say
and uh
she woke up the next day and was too
afraid to go to the course
and so we said well you know it's
understandable why don't you just get in
the car and go to the course and see
when you get there if you can manage it
and she got herself out of bed and went
and managed it and then she passed the
course and then she had a scooter and
could zoom around the city for the next
couple of years and so that was really
good
but it was it was very hard to draw that
line right because
in some sense she'd been victimized by
this arbitrary illness and you know you
you tend as a parent to have an
outpouring of empathy the empathy that
can destroy under those circumstances
because you you cuddle the person
more than is absolutely necessary right
and you have every reason to because
they're suffering like mad
but
you want to be a victim and be a tragic
figure
you know and you might say yes but you
wouldn't if you thought it through
so
and then if someone asked me that
question say in a clinical setting i
would do a little analysis of it's like
okay well you're suffering from this
traumatic experience you want to get
over it we'd have to figure out what the
practical steps might be and that might
be finding somebody to talk to or
there's other ways of dealing with it
but you delve into the practical realm
to sort of address that
so
okay
thank you so much for your talk
on a couple of occasions you
mentioned judeo-christian values
during the talking
in the recent question you
talked of the english common law which
sort of alludes to the divine
one in
every six people in the world live in
india today
india has a democratic secular
constitution
and yet the culture is vedic
and
caste is central
to society
how would you speak
about the freedom of speech
into a culture
that has that in its faith and beliefs
and at the same time in certain fringes
of
the political movement
certain radical ideological movements
there's a belief that
these freedoms are a western
import
so how would you healthily
speak into that culture about upholding
the freedoms well the first thing i
would want to do if i was doing that
practically speaking is i would like to
talk to as many people who hold those
particular views as i possibly could to
find out why they think the way they
think
you know when they say that it's a
western import well what do they mean
because in some sense it is a western
import i mean india has a body of laws
that at least in part is derived from
the english common law tradition and so
it was
imposed upon or introduced into that
culture now it took
to a large degree
and i don't believe that you can import
a propositional structure without the
underlying
imagistic ethos and behavioral
proclivity it just won't work right
because the infrastructure so to speak
isn't there and so
the fact that it has worked at least to
some well i would say some remarkable
degree because india is really a
remarkable success story indicates that
there is some correspondence between the
english common law tradition which
emerged
gradually and in some sense
incrementally and organically out of the
will of the english population
and it matches the same strivings and
proclivities that you might find
elsewhere i would also say that the the
relatively radical comparative economic
success of states settled by
england in its in its history of
colonization let's say also points to a
decent fit between the english common
law tradition and a whole variety of
other cultures that doesn't mean the
match is perfect and so to some degree
the argument is correct it's imposed at
least as a set of propositions but it's
incorrect because i think it reflects
something that's fundamental at the
level we've been discussing today
but if i was trying to mediate those
disputes and i've been having increasing
numbers of conversations with people on
the islamic side of the world trying to
do exactly that is the first thing i
want to do is listen a lot because i
don't know what
i'm so ignorant about such things i just
don't know what people actually think
and so you can't begin to address a
question like that till you find out why
those who stand in opposition to your
claims let's say why they think the way
they think
now the probability that there's no
tradition
say within indian families that
approximates free speech in flourishing
families it's like that's zero
because
it's not possible you know and if it's
just a tyranny let's if it's a tyranny
well
tyrannies aren't sustainable
chimps can't even sustain tyrannies
you know and i'm saying that for
technical reasons you know because there
is this idea that's quite promoted that
complex animals like chimpanzees live in
dominance hierarchies and it's the
meanest toughest male chimp that rules
the hierarchy right and he's like stalin
except in chimp form which actually
places them somewhat higher on the
evolutionary scale than stalin and so
but franz dewal has investigated the
structure of those societies in great
detail and it's simply not the case that
the most tyrannical chimp is on top in
fact the chimp males who sustain
leadership across reasonable amounts of
time are unbelievably reciprocal in
their interactions especially with other
males but they're also particularly
attentive to the females and the infants
and part of the reason for that is well
let's say you're you know joe brute
chimp and you're strutting around like a
fullback and in georgia constantly
showing off your physical prowess it's
like well one day you're a little thick
or a little tired and two chimps that
you've tyrannized will tear you into
pieces
and that happens quite frequently in
chimpanzee disputes where a two
tyrannical male will be literally torn
to pieces because chimps are very brutal
when they get their mind to it and
they're just taken out
and so
this this there's a principle of
reciprocal altruism let's say that's
associated with the free exchange of
ideas and something like
mutual valuation and that's recognition
of the soul i would say on a
metaphysical level that's a precondition
for peace everywhere not just in the
west and that's been propositionalized
and formalized into law in different
ways in different cultures and sometimes
not formalized so much yet let's say
because
many cultures are governed primarily by
ritual and custom rather than you know a
fully articulated body of laws
but
the fact that that does not mean by any
stretch the imagination that english
common law is somehow purely arbitrary
social construction it's like that
that's such a it's a preposterous claim
so
i would start by listening and find out
exactly what the issues are and then
well then proceed from there
uh thank you so much dr peterson for
what you've given us this evening
um you've spoken now in a very
complimentary way about english common
law and and i'm very pleased to hear it
um but
freedom of speech
is something novel uh largely in in
our civilization
um
you just have to think about how
dissenters and catholics were treated in
this country not too long ago you
couldn't go to this institution
if you were not a communicant of the
anglican church
um i'm not an anglican but i sympathize
with them because
if you've got something good
you want
coercive and directive measures to
protect that thing
and in fact
uh
you might be committing a very serious
injustice if you don't
put the
context and structure in place
to prevent people who want to repudiate
that good thing
from
invading and corrupting what has taken
so long to put together
and spoken like a true conservative
and
that's not ironic or denigrating i mean
yes absolutely so how do you reconcile
that
well
there is no permanent reconciliation of
that conundrum
right because and i've traced the
development of that paradox back as far
as i'm concerned back into mesopotamia
past through egypt the egyptians had two
primary
fundamental male gods
and one of them was osiris
and osiris was the founder of the
egyptian state mythologically speaking
kind of like george washington but he
was also the spirit of stone
and so he was the he was the
representation of conservative order
that's a good way of thinking about it
but the egyptians portrayed him as old
and
willfully blind specifically willfully
blind which is extremely interesting
and
subject as a consequence of his willful
blindness to the evil machinations of
set
and the sun sets and so that's how you
know the egyptians thought about the sun
and set
and so seth was the evil uncle
essentially and he
cuts osiris up into his
pieces which were also by the way the
provinces of the egyptian state
and sentences him to the underworld and
then rules instead that's the danger of
an unthinking conservatism because all
our cognitive and social structures
deteriorate with the passage of time
because time changes all things and so
we're always fighting to maintain what
we have and that includes our categories
of perception themselves in the face of
a continual onslaught of novelty at
virtually every level of analysis
while the second god of the of the
egyptians this is a very cursory
overview obviously was horus
and horus was the son of the he was the
rightful son of the true king
raised outside egypt
and alienated in some sense from the
tradition that gave rise to him but he
was simultaneously the falcon and the
egyptian eye that famous egyptian eye
that open eye so he was the god of
attention
and
he his mother is isis and she's the
chaos that arises when order
disintegrates gives rise to the hero
horus goes to the underworld to rescue
his father and the egyptians
conceptualized the soul of the pharaoh
so that would be the proper source of
sovereignty itself as the union of
osiris and horus the living union of li
of osiris and horus so they would
celebrate the pharaoh like you do when a
new king is is uh crowned in the
aftermath of the death of a a reigning
monarch
the king is dead long live the king
right the kingship passes and that's
osiris the tradition passes but it has
to be the tradition has to be living it
has to be allied with attention and the
mesopotamians put a modification on that
which was also magic speech
so
tradition always has to be allied with
attention
and it's like you know this is true if
you own a house you know especially if
it's an older house
well the four walls are there and
they're necessary and you want to
protect it
and uh and preserve them but you have to
maintain them
and sometimes you have to replace them
and how do you tell and the answer is
with a careful and judicious eye
with some humility and gratitude for
what you already have but with some
understanding that in the face of
continual transformation some change is
necessary and then you might ask well
how do you decide when change is
necessary and the answer is
by engaging in political dialogue
mediated by free speech
that is literally because this is an
insoluble problem the conservatives are
not correct
but neither are the progressives
it takes a dialogue between them to
specify the target and it's partly
because the environment itself shifts
and
changes
literally unpredictably and so all we
have is well consciousness itself is the
mechanism that mediates between order
and chaos and
and
political dialogue when it's done in
goodwill is the manifestation of
consciousness in the repair of
mechanisms that need to be sustained and
transformed
and so there's no end to the necessary
dialogue because the future differs from
the past and that's the limit of
conservative thinking right it's like
well the noble traditions it's like fair
enough man if you can walk down a road
that's already been walked down
successfully that's a wise choice
but sometimes you know there's a flood
and the road is changed the underlying
tomography has shifted and then you
wander blindly into into a cliff or into
a pit
so
even as a conservative and conservatives
have more of the temperamental
proclivity let's say to preserve and to
respect
but they still have to be open to the
transformations that are necessary to
keep abreast of the times
and so we try right we winnow through
the wheat and the chaff of the past and
we attempt to garner the wheat and
dispense with the chaff and the only way
we can do that is through continual
dialogue with ourselves honest dialogue
with ourselves and with others
so
um you speak about the concept of the
soul um do you associate this with any
psychological constructs
not any psychological constructs that
are more valid than the notion of the
soul
you know there's
i would say what we mean by soul is
something like animating spirit
and you might say well what's a spirit
and well
that's actually rather easy to answer so
when a child of four is playing house
let's say when a child of four is
playing house she
acts out the role of the mother
but acting out that's a strange thing
right because she doesn't literally
duplicate in her actions or her
perceptions in the game
what she observed her mother literally
doing so for example she didn't go into
her mother's bedroom when her mother
awoke and watched her turn her head in a
particular way to awaken and count the
number of blinks so that she can mimic
that in her play
and you know you think that's absurd but
it's not absurd if it's just mimicry
it's not it's unbelievably sophisticated
so what the girl does is she watches her
mother manifest maternal behavior across
a vast array of instances and she
integrates that with the image of the
mother she's received from all the books
she's been read and all the little
movies she's watched the disney movies
and so forth and she abstracts out the
animating principle of the maternal and
then she embodies that in play and
usually with a little boy and that's
practice for what's going to come later
it's unbelievably sophisticated and
she's embodying a spirit and the spirit
there is the abstraction of the central
animating principle from multiple
embodiments of its manifestation and if
you think children can't do that well
then you don't know anything about
children because they do that all the
time in their pretend play which is a
necessary precursor to healthy
psychological development and so part of
what we refer to as the soul is the
presence of that spirit or maybe even
the capacity of embodying such spirits
and it's very difficult to know how deep
that goes
you know i had a vision at one point of
all the men in my life who've been
particularly influential in a benevolent
way
you know and so and you think well just
the mirror notion of the idea that there
could be a benevolent way
that would unite the acts of benevolence
across a series of men that's all
comprehensible to you that's you take
that as a matter of course when you say
that there are such things as good men
and you can identify them right
something stable about whatever is good
across multiple manifestations of of
incarnation let's say and i saw that
transform into the
the father person of the trinity as the
embodiment of that benevolent spirit now
i don't have any idea what that means
metaphysically because who does but
but that
that spirit manifesting itself within is
certainly part of what we refer to when
we talk about the soul and you can see
that shine through people i mean it's
part of what gives someone charisma it's
part of what elicits the instinct to
imitate in you
you know when you see that even in
simple things when you see a remarkable
athlete do something incredibly
athletic to put the goal to put the
soccer ball the football ball through
the net
to score the goal and everybody leaps to
their feet in celebration of that well
that's that's a celebration of the
divine capacity to hit the target dead
on and it grips you at such a lo a low
level way down inside your soul that
you're compelled to your feet to cheer
and you don't even know what you're
doing
but you enjoy it that's for sure and
that enjoyment is also a sign of
the depth and utility of that response
you see this in all all the things that
people do that are you know so-called
popular entertainment it's unbelievably
sophisticated
the soul is participating in that in the
fullest extent and you know you can say
well there's no use for the religious
there's no necessary use for the
religious terminology it's like
well until you come up with a better
word there's plenty of use for it
because it's a very complex and deep
phenomena and to you know just
cast it into the realm of superstition
in some
casual manner is
it's just not helpful not in any
possible it's not helpful scientifically
it's not helpful ethically it's not
helpful existentially
try treating someone for a while as if
they don't have a soul
just really i mean it just you know
treat them like a deterministic machine
if that's your belief
really act it out you'll be like the
most hated person in town in about 15
minutes well i mean what do you make of
practical evidence like that
i mean you interact with people as if
they're
free souls capable of choosing between
good and evil that's what you do all the
time
and maybe you can addle yourself out of
that by some ridiculous rationalist
ideology but that just means you're
kind of a gambling fool and it's just
going to make you trip over things you
don't even notice in all of your social
interactions and you tell me i don't
care how you think philosophically or
ideologically you bloody well know that
what i just said is true
so and that's true even when you're
interacting with an infant or a small
child it's true when you're dealing with
someone who's elderly and virtually
incapacitated in every way you still see
that divine spark for lack of a better
term and we do lack a better term by the
way you see that everywhere if your eyes
are open and if you're willing to see it
and to the degree that you're responsive
to that then
your actions are guided by love and your
words are guided by truth
thank you very much
[Music]
um
well ladies and gentlemen that concludes
the formal part of the evening's
proceedings thank you so much for coming
along
uh
it would have been so easy for our
speaker tonight never to set foot
in this university ever again
it would have been the easiest thing in
the world for him to go to any of the
other
hundreds of universities that would have
rolled out the red carpet and had him
back after his marathon bout with all
sorts of difficulties over the last two
or three years and i think it's a
testament to the caliber
of his character
uh his generosity
and above all his graciousness
that he was willing not only to come
here and speak to us this evening but
but to spend the best part of two weeks
with us
opening up all his views
to scrutiny to criticism to debate
arif and i have been going at him pretty
much all morning
and he's he's got more of that to come
uh and this is just just a slice of some
of the engagements that that he's going
to be undertaking
uh here and i think it's quite quite
remarkable that he's got that kind of
resilience stamina that that raw
authenticity that has moved and
changed the lives of so many so it's
been a great privilege for me to be part
of this and i hope that the same is true
for you
thank you all so much for coming i
believe that uh colin hewlett here will
be taking uh photos uh with jordan as he
may be tempted to come out uh so you
won't have to uh fumble awkwardly with
your iphones and i'm sure he'll be
around for a few minutes just to to
speak if if you would um
be be
cognizant of his time um but but i'm
sure he'd like to say uh hello to as
many of you as possible if the last few
days walking around the streets of
cambridge are anything to go by
thank you all so much
[Applause]
[Music]
you